building on the three european council
meetings already devoted to the
migration crisis since april this year
EU leaders are expected to focus their
discussions on external borders this is
in fact the fourth summit in only six
months that will mainly focus on the
current migration and refugee crisis as
I see there will be three key objectives
of the summit first to take stock of the
decisions already taken to make sure
that they are in fact implemented to to
give directions at the highest level on
future policies and actions and here I
expect that they will most that leaders
will mostly focus on how to cooperate
with key countries of origin and transit
not least Turkey and Syria and third to
launch a debate on II use future
migration policy in the mid and
long-term strengthening the e use
external borders will include a call for
enlarging the Mandate of frontex and
developing a European border and coast
guard system in support of requesting
member states an increased role for
Frontex would also include the rights to
organize return operations and the
creation of a dedicated returner office
within Frontex
addressing the European Parliament at
the beginning of the month European
Council President Donald Tusk urged his
partners to fully measure the extent of
the current challenges we have to
finally say it loud and clear Europe
without its external borders equals
Europe without Schengen Europe without
its external borders will become a
breeding ground for fear in each and
every one of us and this will lead us
sooner than later to a political
catastrophe EU leaders are also expected
to call for effective follow-up to the
high-level conference on the Western
Balkans route and to achieve concrete
results at the upcoming valletta summit
with African partners on the eleventh
and twelfth of November